je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier à
seulement quatre semaines du concours
j'ai reçu un message sur facebook d'un
élève que je suivais depuis le début de
l'année romain je suis super content
j'ai réussi à mettre la main sur le cour
de louis le grand
plusieurs centaines de pages plein de
références originales
[Musique]
vous avez souvent ce problème vous ne
savez pas comment gérer toutes les
références que vous croyez devoir
connaître pour vos épreuves de
dissertation mais vous devez prendre
conscience d'une chose vous n'avez pas
besoin de beaucoup de références pour
réussir vos dissertation au contraire
c'est même dangereux
l'excès de référence parce que vous
n'arriverez pas à les apprendre même si
vous y arrivez vous aurez du mal à les
mobiliser en dissertation donc la
meilleure stratégie c'est de maîtriser
une quantité limitée de référence
essentielle comme ça vous les apprendre
et à rapidement voulait maîtriserez
facilement et vous serez à l'aise pour
les mobiliser en dissertation
mais surtout ça vous laissera le temps
de travailler ce qui est crucial pour
réussir une dissertation la méthodologie
et la non plus vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation souhaite
en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo c'est un
cours par e-mail donc vous pourrez le
découvrir après cette vidéo ou bien dans
les prochains jours là tout de suite
resté avec moi parce que ce que je vais
vous dire vous faire gagner beaucoup de
temps je vais vous expliquer comment
créer facilement un stock de référence
prêtes à l'emploi pour la dissertation
et comment les apprendre sans risquer le
mal de crâne
[Musique]
pour préparer à prendre efficacement vos
références en vue de la dissertation
je vous recommande très fortement la
méthode du fichier unique en quoi ça
consiste cette méthode
la réponse est dans le nom il s'agit de
regrouper toute l'information et je dis
bien absolument tout dans un seul et
unique fichier
cette manière de faire a deux avantages
d'abord et l'empêcher dispersion vous
n'aurez pas 150 fiches dans 25 dossiers
différents
et le second avantage c'est que vous
pourrez évaluer facilement la quantité
d'informations que représente votre
stock de connaissances je vous rappelle
que vous devez vous méfier de l'ex et
d'information en pratique pour créer
votre fichier unique
je vous conseille d'utiliser google docs
ce parce que c'est un éditeur de texte
simple fiable et que vous pouvez
l'utiliser partout sur n'importe quel
support tant que vous avez internet
et si vous voulez pousser plus loin la
méthode du fichier unique vous pouvez
aller jusqu à stocker tout le contenu
qui concerne la préparation de votre
épreuve de dissertation dans un seul
fichier dans ce cas l'idéal
à mes yeux c'est de stocker les
références dans la première partie du
fichier
ensuite les plans détaillés et enfin les
dissertations entièrement rédigée mais
on n'est pas obligé d'être aussi
radicaux en revanche vous devez à tout
prix structurez votre stock de référence
le
[Musique]
si vous vous contentez de noter les
références dans un fichier unique ça
risque d'être anarchique en particulier
vous ne serez pas si votre stock de
référence couvre tout le programme
vous avez donc intérêt à structurer
votre fichier unique en thème s'il ya un
programme précis pour notre époque des
dissertations et bien reprenez la
structure de ce programme
si votre épreuve porte sur un thème
précis bhl comme hong kong aux écoles de
commerce alors subtilisé ce thème en
soute m
et s'il n'y a pas de programme précis
alors c'est à vous de subdiviser la
matière de l'époque en une quinzaine ou
une vingtaine de sous thèmes maximum est
ce n'est pas très difficile parce que
vous trouverez des listes de thèmes sur
internet ou dans des manuels
ce qui est important c'est que la liste
des thèmes soit exhaustive afin que vous
ayez des munitions pour traiter
n'importe quel sujet pour le vérifier
prenez simplement des sujets tombés ces
dix vingt dernières années à votre
épreuve des dissertations et demandez
vous si vous pouvez les ranger dans un
ou plusieurs thèmes de votre stock de
référence si c'est vraiment impossible
alors il vous manque probablement un ou
plusieurs thèmes une fois que vous aurez
une liste de thèmes exhaustive
il faudra ranger chaque référence dans
le thème auquel elle correspond le plus
et bien sûr vous devrez vous assurer que
vous avez un nombre comparable de
référence dans chaque thème
même s'il est normal que les thèmes les
plus importants soient plus fourni que
les autres voilà vous savez maintenant
comment structurer votre stock de
référence dans votre fichier unique
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous montrer
comment stocker chaque référence
[Musique]
l'excellent informations c'est un danger
à l'égard de la quantité de références
mais c'est aussi un danger qui concerne
le traitement de chaque référence ce que
je veux dire c'est que si vous ne faites
pas attention vous stockez est
probablement trop d'informations à
propos de chaque référence à quoi ça
sert dans la perspective d'une épreuve
de dissertation d'être capable d'écrire
dix pages sur une seule référence à rien
vous devez donc trouver la bonne dose
voici ce que je vous conseille de faire
en pratique noté la référence
c'est-à-dire le titre et l'auteur noter
ensuite l'idée essentielle à laquelle
réfère on servira à apporter du crédit
vous pouvez l'écrire en gras comme moi
et enfin noté 3 à 5 boulette paint pour
expliquer le message essentiel de la
référence ne t'ai pas plus de cinq
bolides poynt essayer même plutôt de
vous limiter à 3 sinon vous basculerez
dans l'excès d'information et ça ne sera
plus rentable pour préparer votre
épreuve de dissertation je vous
conseille de stocker comme ça une
centaine de références grand maximum et
puis n'oubliez pas de vérifier que vous
couvrez bien tous les thèmes une fois
que vous avez produit votre stock de
référence il ne vous reste plus qu'à la
prendre comment faire pour tout retenir
sans se bourrer le crâne
[Musique]
alors moi je n'ai pas fait les
championnats du monde de la mémoire mais
après avoir moi-même préparer les
concours pendant des années et puis
après avoir préparé des centaines
d'élèves à des concours pour lesquels il
faut apprendre beaucoup de références
j'ai aujourd'hui une bonne idée de ce
qui marche et aussi de ce qui est moins
pénible
j'ai trois conseils pour vos premiers
conseils miser sur la régularité ne
révisé pas votre stock de référence la
veille de l'épreuve pendant toute la
nuit
faites-le chaque jour et commencer le
plus tôt possible
premier conseil m'amène au deuxième
révisé par petites doses vous memories
ray mieux en misant comme ça parce qu'il
est très difficile sinon impossible de
rester concentré pendant de longues
heures prévoyez donc de petites sessions
de révision par exemple de 15 minutes à
une demi heure au minimum une par jour
en plus le format de votre stock de
référence se prête bien de petites
sessions de révision puisque vous avez
noté uniquement quelques boulettes poynt
pour chaque référence et il s'y prête
d'autant mieux que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'apprendre par coeur pour
connaître par coeur je connais par coeur
bons numéros de téléphone et bien sûr je
ne laisse jamais appris par coeur c'est
simplement la répétition qui fixera les
références dans votre mémoire
mon troisième conseil c'est donc de vous
contenter de lire votre stock de
référence plutôt que de vous rendre
malade à l'apprendre par coeur
alizée le remiser le et relisez le
encore par petites doses
et comme googledocs existe sur votre
mobile vous pouvez mettre à profit
toutes les circonstances d'un productive
que vous fassiez là que quelque part que
vous soyez bloqués dans le métro bref un
peu partout vous pouvez sortir votre
téléphone et relire pour la énième fois
une partie de votre stock de référence
[Musique]
bon il ne reste plus qu'à comme on dit
en résumé ce que je vous recommande
c'est de créer un fichier unique de le
subdivisée en thème de noter uniquement
quelques boules est pas une pour chaque
référence et enfin de lire et de relire
votre stock de référence chaque jour
pour fixer solidement les connaissances
dans votre mémoire
alors j'étais bien que ce n'est pas
l'histoire dans l'après midi mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'ils doivent ou prendre
le plus de temps ce qui mérite la
majeure partie de votre temps c'est la
méthodologie de la dissertation et j'ai
ce qu'il vous faut pour commencer sur de
bonnes bases
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation souhaite
en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant ou à droite de la vidéo soit
en cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
les références c'est certes secondaire
par rapport à la méthodologie mais ça
fait souvent perdre beaucoup de temps
aux élèves
donc j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo
vous sera utile je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote et
vous étiez sur 1000 et de culture
générale rappelez vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour préparer et
à prendre des références en vue d'une
épreuve de dissertation
à
[Musique]